all eyes are on ukraine as a bloody new
chapter of war appears to be unfolding
right before our very eyes now civilians
are directly in russia's crosshairs now
for quite some time i've been very
critical of ukraine's government and
rampant corruption in the country and by
government officials now the military uh
and president zielinski and ordinary
ukrainians they are fighting valiantly
against an all-out invasion from its
hostile neighbor to the north sadly
innocent men women children they're
dying at the hands of a tiny tyrant
named vladimir putin look at this
six-year-old little girl was mortally
wounded during putin's indiscriminate
shelling in southern ukraine
and as the ap described quote she was
pale her brown hair was pulled back with
a rubber band her bloody pajama pants
were decorated with cartoon unicorns and
her blood is on vladimir putin's hands
so my question to the russian soldiers
tonight following putin's orders and
waging this war on civilians and even
children really is this is this
is this the legacy you want for your
life is this worth it do you have the
courage to stand up against this naked
aggression against innocent men women
and children
now this is a viewer warning this is a
very hard tape to watch but it's
important to see take a look
[Music]
here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now the medical personnel as you can see
in that video as they resuscitate or try
to assess resuscitate
this girl and revive this girl they're
crying
vladimir putin killed that six-year-old
girl vladimir putin started this war
vladimir putin is a murdering thug who
is willing to kill even children to
satisfy his maniacal territorial
ambitions you may notice here below or
the u.s flag is a
ukrainian flag pin for people like that
little girl
standing in solidarity with the innocent
people of ukraine a sovereign country
needlessly attacked by a hostile
dictator now the world needs i would say
a new rule bill maher likes to do new
rules i want this new rule if you are a
murdering tyrant who invades a sovereign
country and you kill innocent men women
and children
and you forfeit your right to lead any
country
now the russian military will hear about
shows like this
they need to stop taking orders from
this murderer they need to take him out
the world needs to agree that putin
should no longer be running russia he's
a murdering authoritarian thug killing
innocent civilians and civilized
countries need to agree that he must be
removed sooner than later and by
whatever means necessary the people
around putin i'll let you figure that
out now scenes like this are everywhere
as russia blasts schools and playgrounds
hospitals large apartment buildings
cluster bombs are going off rocket
attacks non-stop shelling these are not
targeted attacks against ukrainian
military installations no it's vladimir
putin attempting to punish ukrainians
for their resistance and break their
will through a campaign of
indiscriminate violence according to
ukraine's minister of health as of
sunday over 350 civilians have been
killed that number is likely much higher
including many children over the weekend
here's what former president donald
trump had to say at cpac about putin's
hostile invasion take a look
and when you have a weak president who
is not respected by other nations
you have a very chaotic world i have no
doubt that president putin made his
decision
to ruthlessly attack ukraine only after
watching the pathetic withdrawal from
afghanistan the problem
is not that putin is smart
which of course he's smart but the
real problem is that our leaders are
dumb
um
and they so far allowed him to get away
with this travesty and assault on
humanity that's what it is this is an
assault on humanity so sad
putin is playing biden like a drum
you know we played the tape last week of
donald trump without a single note
lecturing in the face of the leader of
nato telling him how idiotic it was we
america paying the bulk of money for
nato to protect western european
countries nato allies from being
attacked by putin and yet they're making
billion dollar deals and are becoming
more and more reliant on vladimir putin
and russia for their energy needs and
how stupid that whole policy is
now i would play with the current
president joe biden said but uh guess
what he was nowhere to be found this
weekend while putin was putting nuclear
weapons in play in this conflict joey
was taking time off in delaware doing
what i don't know
of course president trump is right the
western world is being stupid we need to
understand this thug for who he is we
need to understand that the only thing
that works is strength in fact according
to a harvard harris poll nearly
two-thirds of americans believe this
attack would not have happened under
donald trump why do you think that is
because well putin probably feared
donald trump putin knew that trump if he
said it he meant it he'd do it weakness
invites chaos it invites carnage and by
the way donald trump didn't need he have
to after four years of his presidency he
made america energy independent he made
america a net exporter of energy that is
a big factor in all of this and without
a doubt biden's disastrous withdrawal
from afghanistan he abandoned
our fellow citizens you don't think that
helped embolden every two-bit dictator
around the world i said at the time it
would unfortunately i was right i wish i
was wrong take a look americans held
hostage abandoned behind enemy lines day
198
day one ninety eight wednesday it'll be
200 days joe biden's turn the page he
never mentions them the media mob never
mentions americans left behind green
card holders that are legally allowed in
this country left behind our afghan
allies abandoned stabbed in the back we
promised we'd never do this to them
abandoned all by joe biden if joe were
an honest decent leader he would address
this in tomorrow's state of the union
address well we could talk about all the
things that he should address that he
won't address he would announce a new
wave of sanctions against putin's oil
and gas industry and vow to expand
american energy production in order to
meet the energy needs of not only our
country but the energy needs of our
allies in europe our nato allies joe's
economic energy policies they've now
hurt every american family with a
40-year high in inflation we pay more
for every item we buy more to fill our
tanks more to heat and cool our homes
why because everything costs more to get
it to the store it costs more for a
gallon of gasoline i'm almost paying
twice what we used to pay he gave up
america's energy independence he
compromised our national security he
compromised the world security who would
think you know after inheriting energy
independence that joe biden literally
imports 232 million barrels of oil from
russia and a billion uh uh
barrels of oil from iran for the first
time since 1991
or 600 million barrels of oil from opec
joe biden's beholden to the radical new
green deal socialist he won't admit that
he's wrong he won't reverse course and
he won't again become a net exporter of
energy like the
economy he inherited italy is even now
considering reviving the country's coal
plants to break their energy dependence
on russia so at a bare minimum joe
should block the us from importing all
russian oil and by the way every decent
country in the world should put that
main sanction on vladimir putin and
russia that's the sanction that will
mean the most to putin and that's the
one sanction they have not put in place
any sanction that doesn't hit russia's
energy sector is pointless remember
russia you know as a is a gas station as
john mccain said masquerading as a
country but guess what
none of this is going to happen
apparently the biden administration has
no problem continuing killing the
keystone xl pipeline but blocking
russian oil and gas imports is totally
out of their control really take a look
what is the stance of the us and buying
russian gas at this point at this point
are we ready to pledge not to buy any
more russian gas
well uh as you know it's really uh let
me give you actually kind of an update
on this because it's a it's um i think
there's been a little confusion one
moment
um
so as it relates to
russian gas u.s government doesn't
dictate where the u.s market sells our
own oil and gas products nor where it
acquires crew to refine products from
for domestic consumption
now clearly the climate alarmist cult
inside the new green deal democratic
socialist party they're fully in charge
they take top priority over the american
people over the world peace that we
would have being energy independent a
net exporter of energy and under their
leadership america the world is falling
apart take a look at your screen since
joe biden was inaugurated coven 19
deaths are over 500 thousand gas prices
nearly doubled and again inflation at
over a forty year high add to that the
border crisis the crisis in afghanistan
and now a full-blown war in europe
breaking out right before our eyes and
it's clear that our state of the union
well guess what the state of the world
is not in a great place because america
is not leading and america doesn't have
a strong leader and i bet joe biden's
probably asleep at this hour and he
probably doesn't know what day it is but
tomorrow according to reports we are to
expect joe biden to double down on the
new green deal socialism platform as a
magical cure-all for america's woes that
is the dumbest policy you could ever
embrace it's no wonder joe biden even
abc washington post poll has it at an
all-time low at 37 percent with an even
lower 30 percent of independence
approving of the job as president in the
white house we're going to have a lot
more on tomorrow's speech in a moment